this episode is brought to you by
headspace life can be stressful
even under normal circumstances 2020 has
challenged
even the most resilient people i know
it's highlighted
just how much we all need stress relief
that goes beyond quick
fixes or really the hope for just a
one-and-done
band-aid quick is fine but we need stuff
that is durable and that's where
headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million
downloads so if people keep telling you
to try meditation and you're like when
would i do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
minutes headspace can change your life
headspace
offers a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation
headspace can really help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute
sos meditation for you need some help
falling asleep headspace has wind down
sessions their members swear by and for
parents headspace even has morning
meditations you can do with your kids
headspaces approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy i think
it's puddicum could be putty comb i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic
voice imaginable and i did a three
minute meditation something like that
it's easy it's fundamental and it always
puts me in a better
space so i'm going through the basics
even though i've meditated for years i'm
going through the basics once again
and i would suggest to anyone that they
consider starting there
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you
on your schedule anytime anywhere we all
want to feel happier
we all want more peace and headspace is
meditation made
simple go to headspace.com tim
that's headspace.com tim for a free one
month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace
this is the best deal offered right now
for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my feet
it's helped with my plantar fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it
in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours i
love this thing
and the all-new gen 4 theragun has a
proprietary brushless motor that is
surprisingly quiet
it's easy to use and about as quiet as
an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g-u-n there's no substitute
for the gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragon app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragon.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th air
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine use them on their it
bands after long runs
there are a million ways to use it and
the gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 dollars i said i have two i
have the prime
and i also have the pro which is like
the super cadillac version my girlfriend
loves these soft attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim at this altitude i can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands start
shaking
can i ask you a personal question now
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview and
deconstruct world-class performers of
all different types from all different
fields
my guest today is david m rubinstein he
is co-founder and co-executive chairman
of the carlyle group
a global investment firm with
approximately 230 billion dollars under
management
mr rubinstein is chairman of the boards
of trustees of john f kennedy
center for the performing arts and the
council on foreign relations a fellow of
the harvard corporation
and a regent of the smithsonian
institution he is an original signer of
the giving pledge
and has made transformative gifts for
the restoration or repair of the
washington monument
kennedy center smithsonian national
archives national zoo in the national
museum of
african american history and culture mr
rubinstein is also host of the david
rubinstein show peer-to-peer
conversations on bloomberg tv
and the author of the american story
subtitle
conversations with master historians and
his latest
how to lead subtitle wisdom from the
world's greatest ceos founders and game
changers
he is a graduate of duke university and
the university of chicago law school
you can find him online at david
rubinstein
david welcome to the show thank you very
much for having me tim
if we hop back to
your i suppose adolescence or or
childhood depending on how we want to
frame it
what direction did you think you were
going to take
when you were say in your early teens at
that point did you have an inkling of an
idea
of what you wanted to be or what you
wanted to do
i did i was very interested in politics
maybe because
my sixth grade teacher drummed into me
the uh and all of my classmates the
inaugural address of john kennedy and
how it was poetry in prose form we
studied it
and like many young people in those days
we were attracted to the image the
vigorous image the young image of a
president who contrasted so much
with the his predecessor dwight
eisenhower in terms of image and youth
and vigor and so forth
and so i uh always thought that politics
was the highest calling of mankind as i
would say
then and so i was interested in going
into politics and then i thought
to go into politics you have to be a
lawyer and to be a lawyer you have to
learn how to read and write
reasonably well and talk reason well and
those were probably skill sets that i
thought i had
i didn't think i was a great scientist
in terms of going to medical school
and i i really didn't know about
business because business was not
something that was
really very common in those days this is
the 1950s and 60s
there were no hedge funds there were no
private equity funds there were no tech
startups
if you went in the business in those
days you only had three choices
you went into your family business which
was typically a
small business you would join a gigantic
company like jp morgan
guaranty or or procter gamble or you
might find a local
business in your city that wasn't famous
nationally but basically had a local
kind of business but those are the
business opportunities people didn't
think about getting wealthy and
i didn't aspire to make a lot of money i
didn't think it was realistic so i
really wanted to be
in politics and be a lawyer to get into
politics
when did ted sorensen enter the picture
and
for those who don't recognize the name
as i didn't who is
ted sorensen you can tackle that in
either direction when john kennedy was
elected to the united states senate
in 1952 uh he started hiring new
staffers he had been in the house of
representatives from 1946 on he served
three terms in the house
and he was elected to the senate and um
he started hiring some young people he
interviewed a young man who was then i
think 25 or six
named ted sorensen who'd been first in
his class at university nebraska law
school
very smart person but didn't have roots
in in washington d.c but he came there
looking for a job
he had a choice between scoop jackson
then a senator from
washington state or the new john kennedy
he decided kennedy would
offer a greater career opportunity he
became
his top advisor in many ways but also
his speech writer
and later john kenny would say his
intellectual blood bank
and so john kennedy's wonderful rhetoric
his great speeches his
his great writings the profiles and
courage were to some extent written
with the great help of a man named ted
sorensen and so when ted sorensen
stayed with john kenny when he elected
president he became his
top i would say advisor on many
different things but principally as top
speech writer
and so i admired a man who had written
these brilliant words
and so at the time that i was getting
ready to
leave the law school and go to law firms
i decided i wanted to go to the firm in
new york that he was at
in part because a lot of people in that
firm paul weiss had political
backgrounds adley stevenson had been
there
arthur goldberg had been there ramsay
clark had been there
ted sorensen many other prominent people
were there i thought it had the
combination of what i wanted a lot of
uh good legal training but also people
cared about politics and government
i thought if i worked with ted sorensen
a bit he could help me ultimately get
into
government myself are some of the best
and this is coming from someone who
knows nothing about speed writing
especially
from a political perspective are many of
the
best speech writers in politics
extremely young is it like professional
sports because i'm thinking of
your description of ted sorensen i'm
thinking of
john favreau the the speechwriter for
obama and not the director is that
common
to find uh that that speechwriters have
their power zone
in earlier years yes for a number of
reasons
you know mathematicians are generally
said to peak at their you know made the
age of 30.
you don't find a lot of mathematicians
doing great things at the age of 60 or
so
and in the speech writing world it
requires a round-the-clock kind of
dedication to writing because
you're working for a senator or a
governor or president or an infinite
number of speeches you have to write
and it requires a pretty good work
quotient you know when you're 60 or 70
you probably can't work
quite those hours that you can when
you're in your 20s and 30s pulling
all-nighters
also um it's not a highly paid
profession it's not like you get equity
in a
in a private equity transaction so
you're not highly paid and therefore you
tend to get people who are generally
single
uh or maybe newly married and people who
are young and that's what you see in all
presidential
uh staffs when we look at their speech
writing contingent so yes that's
probably true
uh ted sorensen became the top
speechwriter 31 and then when john
kennedy
died uh from assassination i think ted
sorensen was then probably uh
34-35 so you think about it at the age
of 34 35 his whole
career kind of ended in some respects he
then became made himself a very good
lawyer he stayed with president johnson
for a while but
but he was always known as the great
speechwriter
in the intellectual blood bank for um
for john kennedy
intellectual blood bank that's a term
i'm gonna have to find a way to use
at some point richard nixon had said uh
you know richard nixon who wasn't famous
for those uh
those great uh speeches and maybe you
know john kenny deserves some credit for
he was a reasonably good writer himself
and he he he aspired to be a writer how
did he not go into politics so i didn't
want to make it sound like it's all
sorenson
but richard nixon once said to somebody
if i had had ted sorensen
as my speechwriter i could have given
those great speeches and maybe i would
have been elected president in 1960.
the secret weapon weapon x i've read a
number of
descriptions and also heard you describe
being told when you were practicing law
some version of hey pal you're not
really cut out for this maybe you should
try something else
did that affect you if i'm getting
that that part of the story right or
would did you just view it as a
prerequisite intermediate step to
politics and as such
that that did not really affect you on
any deep level
i've said that many times and it's
somewhat tongue-in-cheek i i was nobody
was saying i was a supreme court clerk
or going to be the greatest lawyer of
all time
i suspect had i stayed at all wise i
might have
worked my way up maybe to becoming a
partner it took about seven or eight
years to become a partner
but i might not have um in my class it
started at paul weiss we had about 24
25 people i think only two stayed long
enough or three stayed long enough to be
partnered
so maybe i wouldn't have made it but i
would say i was an okay lawyer but a
great lawyer
has a dedication to the practice of law
that maybe i didn't have
they have an attention to detail that
maybe i didn't have they have a relish
for uh kind of having blinders on and
just focusing on these narrow issues
and which is a very good skill and i was
always interested in so many different
things i had more eclectic interests so
i'm not sure i would have been a great
lawyer but had i been a reasonable
lawyer
and stayed i didn't think the life of a
lawyer was all that great you basically
were you know had clients you weren't
gonna make a lot of money as a lawyer
relative to what you were making
business
you were um you know captive of the
clients and so i
i really was interested not in
practicing law and probably not living
in new york at the time so i really was
interested in going to washington
and getting involved in politics and
maybe going to the white house
well let's hop to the white house next
and this is always
a wobbly terrain for me because i
unfortunately consider myself
at least moderately politically
illiterate
or uninformed at the very best i'm
trying to remedy that but it's it's
one baby step at a time so how did you
end up as
i understand the deputy domestic policy
advisor under president carter how did
you get there
most people who get white house jobs uh
tend to work
in the campaign one way or the other and
they know the candidate in one way or
the other
at a young age you have people who are
in their 23 4
5 6 7 8 they're working in campaigns so
my case
i got a job on capitol hill that ted
sorensen helped me get
the person i was working for senator
birch bai was running for president i
thought that was a twofer i get to work
on capitol hill
he might get to be president so i could
learn something about congress but i
might get to work in the white house
he dropped out shortly after i joined
his uh senate staff
and then an opportunity came to
interview for the stamp
that was being assembled for the general
election campaign in 1976 for jimmy
carter
jimmy carter had had only one full-time
staff person
working on his policy staff and in those
days that was even then it was small
and that person ultimately had to go out
and hire a staff for the general
election campaign
he came to capitol hill interviewed some
bright young capitol hill people i got
an interview
he hired me i went to work down in
georgia for three months of the general
election we won the election
my boss became the assistant to the
president for domestic policy and i was
one of his two deputies
and so i got a job as his deputy in an
office in the west wing and
here i am 27 three years out of law
school and all of a sudden
i'm making more than i would have been
making in uh in in private practice as
it turns out for some
strange reason and then i'm you know i
got office in the west wing and i'm
running around on air force one and
marine one with the president united
states so
pretty heady stuff i would say so
would you describe yourself as qualified
for that position number one and what
does
in any case what does the first
say month of being on that job
look like for you in terms of your
priorities and how you're thinking about
executing well i wasn't qualified by the
traditional standards of
of having a lot of experience but you
know if you look at all white house
staffs they often are filled with
at you know the junior level with young
people these are people that work in
campaigns and they get rewarded by
working on the white house staffs
some of them turn out to be really great
and some of them turn out to be less
than great
and i knew a lot of people from the
campaign so i actually uh was pretty
conversant with the people who got the
jobs in the white house
even though i was not a georgian and i i
had not been involved with jimmy carter
really and i had not even met jimmy
carter
until about two weeks into the white
house i never met him in the campaign
so i uh you know i was a little unusual
yes
and was there a curriculum so to speak
or a way of
learning on the job i'm just i'm i'm
curious how someone who seems to be such
a diligent
student uh in in all things who has
what seems to be clearly an almost a
dedic memory i mean you
you have such a incredible
ability to retain facts and figures and
to then use them in speeches and
fundraising and so on
how did you approach learning the job of
deputy domestic
policy advisor right i would say that
the first thing you mentioned is
i can remember things pretty well and
details of
things 10 20 30 years ago or things i
read
trying to find my keys from time to time
can be a challenge
particularly if they're in my hand so
you do find this bizarre thing that you
you can't remember where you put your
glasses even though they might be on
your forehead
but you can remember something to happen
in 1312 or something i don't know
i don't know why the brain works that
way but the answer you're quite specific
question
uh what what jimmy carter wanted to do
was to to do
everything at once he didn't really want
to focus on one or two priorities and
people told him that was a mistake but
he said look
um as many presidents do if you're so
smart how come i'm president united
states and you're not
so many presidents say that and so he
basically thought look now's a chance to
get things done that he wanted to get
done
so we tried everything so we have to
have bills to congress we have to
respond to things that congress wants to
do
and so my job was to help my boss who
was the domestic advisor who had known
carter
for quite some time and so he had really
good insights as the carter
on what carter wanted and we had a
domestic policy staff about 40 people
and so my job was to help coordinate
things with them they had specialties in
various areas we had to worry about
agriculture housing
energy whatever it was my job would help
coordinate write some memos
and things like that and then the 10
meetings where these discussions are
are being held and it was a little heady
when your
your parents have not graduated from
college or high school
and then one day they're they're
standing on the south lawn because i
invited them
and they see me walking out of the oval
office with just jimmy carter and me and
a secret service
and we're getting on marine one to go
some trip and so they were kind of
saying how did this happen
of course i'm saying that to myself how
did this happen but lots of times in
life people get jobs that they're not
really that qualified for
and it wasn't that unusual there were a
lot of people who probably had less
qualification than i did
and some had more qualifications than i
did and that's just the way all white
house staffs tend to work
we're going to get to business of course
to the finance world and so on but but
before we do i'm curious
up to that point in time in retrospect
what were some of the best decisions
that you made
or investments of time up to that point
in your
career i mean you strike me as very at
least in
in many respects in many facets of your
life quite methodical
thoughtful analytical so whether by
design or by luck
what were some of the best decisions
that you made
up to that point well i guess there are
some personal ones i
decided not to drink alcohol so i've
never tasted alcohol um the club that i
was in
the lancers club i would say that uh the
judge
probably didn't think young men should
be drinking alcohol and i just
adopted that rule and that was probably
a good thing i did i saved a lot of time
and didn't get any trouble
and the same with other kinds of things
like drugs or things like that so
kind of staying on the straight narrow
was probably helpful
uh secondly being a hard worker i
generally had the view that if you
worked hard it was better than if you
didn't work hard you're
more likely to produce something and get
something done and so i
generally made myself into a bit of a
hard worker
and admired people who had done that as
well
and so i also read a lot i tried to
perfect
three skills uh very simple ones learn
how to
write i had a very good high school
teacher and he taught me
another in my class how to write the
king's english in a way that's
comprehensible and so i like to write
and i thought i was reasonably good at
it so i was pretty good at writing memos
or
things like that secondly learn how to
talk
you know if you have to learn how to
communicate
as well orally if you're going to get
somewhere in life and i so i took
advantage of every opportunity i could
to learn how to speak by taking speaking
engagements or just
watching people speak or reading about
people who have been great speakers and
practicing the kind of things they had
done
and then just reading everything i could
just
reading just reading every newspaper
every magazine article i could that was
relevant to what i was doing
just soaking up as much information as i
could and so those kind of basic skills
were helpful to me
and ultimately in the end if you're
willing to do all that and put the hours
in you can you can get somewhere in life
i've watched a number of talks that
you've given including
uh one at oxford from a handful of years
ago i think 2018.
right if you were teaching a
freshman seminar on you could pick
either speaking well or writing well and
understanding they're quite closely
related in a lot of ways
how might you go about teaching either
of those would there be any particular
exercises
or principles that you would put forth
well like in anything it's practice so
in
in writing uh writing as much as you can
writing in my case memos or writing
other things that people might read
publicly
but just practicing writing having
somebody go over with you and
pointing out the mistakes and learning
how to make sure you understand grammar
and punctuation
when jimmy carter was president he was
obsessed with
proper punctuation and grammar and so
all of us were very careful we sent a
memo to him
uh it had to be you know written
extremely well because he was very
careful about those kind of things
in terms of speaking morally
it's it's an important skill that i
think many people don't practice as much
as they should but
in my case i try to take advantage of
all the opportunities i might get to
speak somewhere and learn how to
speak in a way that works for for each
person now if you watched that speech
and i wasn't
i remember that event i was invited to
go to oxford's the oxford i think it's
called political union or
uh i think that's what it was called and
uh so i you know i've never been to
oxford so i get there and
and they say okay well this is a great
thing lots of famous people come here
i said really who was the speaker right
before me they said well last week we
had monica lewinsky
i said oh okay so i you know didn't know
whether uh i should
i was a step up or step down i don't
know in terms of attracting people she
probably attracted a lot more people
than i did
but if you saw that speech what i have
tried over the years to develop a style
that works for me but may not work for
other people
which is to not read from a text so if i
give a commencement speech
or any kind of speech these days i i
generally what i do is i write down the
what i want to say so somebody might
want a written text or i might outline
it
and then i try to commit it to memory
and i find when you're looking at an
audience
and you can look at them in the eye and
not looking up and down up and down up
and down
you can be a more effective speaker but
you know everybody
can't do that style many people get
nervous about not being able to remember
exactly what they were supposed to say
and my own view is it's not that hard if
you practice it
so if you watch speeches i give or
interviews that i do i don't use
notes my view is that i can commit most
of it to memory and if i forget one or
two things nobody will really remember
that
and i think it's easier to have a
conversation that way it's also easier
to give a speech
that is going to be listened to as
opposed to when you have your head
buried down and you're just reading from
a text
so the oxford union presentation portion
was probably 30 to 40 minutes and
you have a a very action-packed
word per minute rate you do not
dilly-dally
so you get a lot in it's probably you
know hour to an hour and a half
worth of material for a lot of other
people how do you commit that to memory
is it reading it over and over again is
it practicing it
as a rehearsal how do you what is your
process
my process is if i'm going to give a
speech and it works
typically of the kind of speech i gave
at oxford is a speech i've given before
so it's not
that hard a speech talking about my
background and the things i'm working on
or whatever it might be
um so it's not that difficult to do if
i'm giving a commencement speech you
want to say something a little bit
different
i do type the trend tend to write it out
and then i try to
take the written thing and then i'll say
that i'll give it to the university if
they want to have a written record of
what i was
you know my actual text and then i'll
commit the 15 points into the key ones
and just kind of memorize the key points
and i
can do it because my brain works in a
certain way i remember after point one
the logical thing is to have point two
and after point two the logical thing
would go to point three
and so it's it's really not that hard um
i find that people who actually have
notes in front of them
actually stumble more than people that
don't have notes
because when you're reading out from a
page sometimes you might misread
something you might
mispronounce something it's actually
easier when you don't have notes in my
in many respects though i have been
surprised honestly
uh sometimes people who are gifted
gifted
speakers sometimes they they have notes
in front of them and they're just better
at reading a text than i guess i am but
sometimes i've seen some really
famous uh lawyers and other people
who are great political figures they
still feel uncomfortable
in giving a speech without a note and
they want to have it written down and i
understand that everybody has their own
style but that that's my style is to
kind of
look at the audience and talk to them or
look to the person you're interviewing
and talk to him or her
and not use notes it's it's not as hard
as it sounds honestly
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by ship
station i've been super impressed with
these guys
shipstation is the shipping software
with the most
five-star reviews now speaking as a
former e-commerce ceo
back in a previous incarnation when i
was shipping tens of thousands and then
hundreds of thousands of
products this is what i wish i had way
back
in the day as folks adapt to this
changing world these strange times we're
all going to be buying more stuff online
than ever before
and if you're an ecommerce seller or if
you want to be selling more
online you have to ask yourself are you
ready to meet the demands
of our new delivery economy
you can be ready with shipstation and
lots of my friends use them so why ship
station when you're selling online
getting a lot of orders out fast can be
super hard i've experienced this first
hand
how do you keep track of who gets what
which shipping carrier should you use
how do you process
refunds how do you process returns how
do you do all of that are you getting
the best
rates shipstation helps online sellers
of any size get orders out quickly
save money on shipping costs and keep
customers happy and right now
my dear listeners you can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use
offer code tim tim there's absolutely no
risk
you can start your free trial without
even entering your credit card info just
visit shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type
in tim one more time shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top
and type in tim that's me tim check it
out
how did you decide and when at what age
did you decide to
become an entrepreneur well um
i didn't really decide at a young age i
wanted to do that
my goal in life was simply to work in
the white house
and i thought okay i got my go i'm 27
years old i'm at the white house
and i thought that in the second term
carter would be re-elected because most
presidents get re-elected
most obviously we've seen the one that
didn't get reelected recently but most
get reelected
the ones that didn't in the 20th century
though were gerald ford george herbert
walker bush and
jimmy carter but they get reelected my
thought was jimmy carter is a really
smart person
ronald reagan is very old i thought how
can he get you know
he can't get out of bed in the morning
he's 69 years old i'm now 71.
so i don't think it's quite as old as it
used to in fact he looks kind of young
now 69 how he was
voted so young but i thought how could
carter lose he's so smart yes we had
hostage problems but we'll get the
hostages out
yes we had inflation it wasn't his fault
yes we had gas lines but it wasn't his
fault
so you there's a cognitive dissonance
that works in the white house
like in any place that has power i guess
and basically your view is anything
that's bad information
it's because people don't know as much
as you know if anybody knew as much as
you know they would make the same
decisions you would make
and most presidents have that same view
which is they're making the decisions
because they have the best information
coming to them
and then they make their decisions and
then those decisions when they're
implemented
should work out if they don't it's
because they're not communicating
properly or people aren't understanding
properly
so i thought carter would ultimately be
understood better communicate better and
he get reelected because he's running
against an old man who was too
conservative
when that didn't work out i had to do
what you know you may or may not have
had to do in your life
which is to recalibrate my life so all
of a sudden people told me what a
brilliant young man i was
i called him up and said okay i'm still
brilliant i'm ready to come work for
your law firm you wanted me to work for
you
when carter was president i didn't want
to leave that now i'm ready to
to work and i hadn't planned on any of
this before because i
i had always thought carter would be
re-elected and i would be in the second
term maybe the senior domestic advisor
my boss might have become attorney
general or something like that so i
would have risen up and
had i done that i probably would have
been i had a different life because
if i had stayed another four years with
carter i would have been old enough then
34 35
to go get a great job practicing law in
washington probably because i would have
been more
well-known and then i would have settled
into the convenient life and the easy
life of being a washington lawyer
lobbyist you
you have clients and you kind of
influence pedo a little bit maybe you
practice a little bit law
you make some speeches and then you go
back into another administration you go
back and forth and eventually someday
you become a cabinet officer
if you're lucky and that's probably what
what i was destined to do
and my parents would have thought that
was great and i would have thought it
was great but what happened was i
couldn't get a job practicing law so
easily because i really wasn't qualified
only practice law for two years in new
york
and nobody really wanted to carter white
house aide so like all the famous law
firms i interviewed with none of them
gave me an offer
and so i really had a struggle for about
six months to get a law firm to hire me
for
any position even a lowly position
finally a mid-sized law firm
either felt sorry for me or they took a
chance and gave me a job but
at a mid-level position i wasn't a
partner or anything and so i started
doing it and i realized that i didn't
like it
i wasn't that good at it i didn't have a
lot of contacts i didn't have a
specialty
and i realized if you don't love what
you're doing you can never be great at
it
nobody ever won a nobel prize hating
what they do you have to love it
and so i as i became eventually i became
a partner in this law firm
but i realized every partner meeting was
really just talking about how much money
we're making or not making and i
realized it was really a business that
had been seen as a profession when i was
in law school
but it's really a business i figured if
i'm going to be in business i might as
well be in a business that makes more
money and
i kind of switched a bit i had never
cared about money but once i was out of
government
and i started to have a family and kids
i started caring about more money more
and so i said i'm going to be in the
money-making business i might as well be
in a more profitable business
and i read about bill simon who had
started a uh buyout firm in new jersey
it worked very well and that's when i
decided i will try to start my own
buy-out firm in washington dc
so bill simon i think and uh please
fact-check me from not getting this but
took 1 million
two years later had turned it into 80
million something like that
so pretty good correct pretty good input
output for those who don't know what
does a buyout firm do
okay in the early days when buyouts were
done
what they were basically doing is they
were taking a business that somebody
didn't want
like he bought gifts and greeting cards
from rca or a family-run business where
there's nobody left in the family really
wants to run it
and they were buying it using a lot of
leverage zen caught a leverage buyout
and a lot of leverage meant that you
were basically putting in one
to five percent of the purchase price in
equity
money that was at risk theoretically and
then you're
borrowing you know 95 to 99 percent of
the purchase price
so if you buy something let's say to
make it understandable
uh let's say at five times the cash flow
in other words the five times
the cash flow the free cash flow that
comes off the earn
off the company you buy something for
five times cash flow
you're levering it up 95 to five if you
make some
fixes in the company and you improve it
in a couple years you'll probably be
earning a lot more
and then you can sell the company or
take it public and make a pretty good
profit and the people that did this in
the early days of the
i buy out boom let's say in the 1970s
and 80s
they were making spectacular rates of
return to put it in context for
everybody who would understand it
let's suppose you put your money in a
bank account in those days you got a
three or four percent rate of return on
your bank deposit something like that
and maybe you put your money in the
equity market and equity fund you got a
six or seven percent rate of return
well in the the way these buyouts were
working people were getting 20 and 30
and 40
rates of return so people you know we
said that's a pretty good business i'd
like to invest
in that business for working that
business so a buyout is basically an
effort to
fix a company make it better it's
different than venture capital where
you're creating something
brand new but you're taking an older
company and and
managing it better than people did
before you're incenting the managers
giving them a piece of the equity
and the buyout boom boomed in part
because
the first people that started venture
capital and buyouts
uh and this was so risky then that
venture capital was called ad venture
capital
it was so risky um they they went to
their first backers and they said you
know what
this is risky business and we're going
to take a lot of risk here it might not
work out but we want to be rewarded if
we really do something so
don't just give us a one percent fee
like we're managed we're an investment
banker or something we'd like let's say
20 of the profits and the people said
well okay
20 of the profits of their profits we
get our money back and you we get 80
of the profits you get 20 they agree to
that and so
that really fueled the whole industry
because if you get 20 of the profits on
a lot of money and you make
four or five six times your money you
can make a fair amount of money as a
person doing this kind of business were
the
buyouts at the time effectively all
leveraged buyouts sort of in these kind
of barbarians at the gate
yes uh njr nabisco of that era were
were we were talking in almost every
case about
leveraged buyouts yes yes
the early days these were called for the
first days it was called bootstrap deals
you were bootstrapping yourself to
to a company or you were basically
bootstrapping yourself because you
didn't have any money you were basically
borrowing all the money
they later became called leveraged
buyouts
but the word leverage became odious so
they went to management buyouts implying
it was friendly
to some leverage buyouts were unfriendly
then buyout became unfriendly
or became a word that wasn't so like so
they went to private equity
and so now private equity probably isn't
like i haven't found a better name
but yes in the early days uh in the bill
simon
example i think he put in a million
dollars he made 80 million dollars
i think he only had about one percent of
the equity in the deal in other words
they only put in one percent they
borrowed 99 the banks in those days for
whatever reason willing to let you do it
the regulators in those days weren't
even focused on it because these deals
were small
they weren't going to affect the
regulatory system that much because they
weren't that many buyouts being done
um in the rjr deal you referred to the
barbarians of the gate for those who
don't know that's a famous book
written about the rjr takeover done by
kkr
in 1989 when kkr did that deal they beat
out
a couple other buyers but they did the
deal at uh with five percent
equity and 95 debt and nobody at the
time really thought that that
leverage percentage was was too high or
too low they thought it was okay it was
consistent with what was normal then
the way that structure the debt though
had some problems i won't
get into a technical thing but it was it
was a lot of debt
so it worked it didn't really work out
so well uh because of the way the debt
was structured but
but had the um deal worked out better if
you have five percent of the equity and
you control the whole company
that five percent can make a lot of
money and so buyouts uh
you know were tended to be really
relatively profitable in part
and they incent to people to go into the
business in part because you got 20
of the profits and you know 20 of
somebody else's money can can be very
profitable if you do a good
deal where it makes two three four five
times your money i would love to
dig into this a bit because i i rarely
have
conversations about uh either leveraged
buyouts or
private equity on this show uh the
listeners of the show who've listened
for a long time are probably more
familiar with venture capital just
because that's
a world i was involved with for a long
time we've had investors like mark
andreessen and reed hoffman and many
others
on the podcast which has a
say a 2 and 20 or in some cases a 3 in
structures the management feed and then
the the
the profit incentive in the case of
assuming debt some of the examples that
you gave
that sort of strikes terror into my
heart not understanding how these deals
are
are really structured the subtleties of
them what are
the threats and how do you or risks i
should say and how do you mitigate
the risks of things going sideways in in
those deals
in the early days of the buyout world
the people doing the deals were former
investment bankers to some extent so
they were finance
people and they were borrowing 95 of the
purchase price
well that's a problem because um if the
economy goes south
then your your projections are probably
going to be off
you don't have a lot of margin um in the
late 1980s
around the time of the rjr deal a lot of
people were doing deals with five
percent equity and then the economy went
into a uh
recession and there was a kind of a
bubble burst
and a lot of the deals went under and so
the buyout industry reshaped itself
and it basically began doing deals where
you were putting in
20 percent of the capital structure and
then 30
now it could be 40 or so i mean
sometimes it's even been 50
and also the debt has been structured
differently so it's a little bit harder
to default
because they have covenants that are
looser let's say on the default but one
of the major things that's changed
is that today all the buyout firms have
people in those firms who are not
so much former investment bankers but
they're people that have worked in
operational companies who have real
management expertise so as soon as you
buy a company
you say okay here's our 100-day plan our
30-day plan we're going to change the
company
dramatically by making these management
improvements now
in the early days buyouts these were
relatively novel kinds of things
today they're well known in fact public
companies do the same things that
private equity people do in many
respects because the techniques are
pretty well known
and so today i'd say the risk is much
less because it that that
often has it's harder to default on it
you have so much more equity underneath
it
you have people much more expert in how
to run the i oversee these companies
watching them and so it's much less
risky now the returns are much less too
the days of 30 and 40 buyout returns
are very very few because unless you get
lucky on a deal
um it's unlikely you're going to get a
40 50
rate of return now that happens from
time to time you will see some deals
from time to time but
generally people put their money in a
fund and a fund does 20 or 30 deals
you know it'll probably in this day and
age i would say average from the
mid-teen
net rate of returns that's to say 15 16
annualized which is pretty good when
interest rates are more or less at zero
um the old days people thought they
could get twenty percent net internal
rate return or even twenty five percent
net internal rates return that that's
that's harder to do today because
there's more competition
when i started carlisle there were maybe
250 buyout firms or investment firms of
its type around the entire world
today they're probably you know i'd say
six or seven thousand
so it's more competition prices have
been driven up
i would also people often ask me where
did the how did you get 20
who came up with that and why is it
called a carried interest and let me
explain
um the first 20 really in the modern age
was the first hedge fund was done
pretty much after world war ii and the
first person who built the hedge fund he
asked for 20
of the profits it's not clear yes for 20
but the investors agreed
the first venture capitalist again i
said earlier the adventure campus
they they kind of asked for 20 as well
and their their investors
uh said okay nobody knows exactly why
they people
ask for 20 now versus 25 or 10
but it's it i analogize it to the the
days in the week
it kind of seems like five days of
working works and two days of rest five
and two out of the seven
that seems to be normal around the world
as a way to kind of uh
modulate the amount of time you have to
work and so forth well 80 20 seem like
for most investors a fair way to split
profits we get 80
of our profits back we get our capital
back and we'll give you guys who work
very hard 20
in the old days in the middle ages the
venetian ship owners
used to send empty ships to asia to
bring back spices
and the people that worked on the ships
would get a piece of the profits
they would carry they would have a
carried interest they have an interest
in what they carried back from asia so
if you carry back a lot of spices from
asia
you have an interest in it it's called
your carried interest and it was
20 so maybe it came from there who knows
but any event um that that's where the
phrase probably came from and
and 20 seems relatively normal but as
you pointed out in the venture world
the best venture people today are
probably getting 30 returns
30 carried interest and sometimes now
people
in the buyout world in order to attract
more capital or do things uh differently
they might
take a slightly lower than 20 return 20
carried interest
slightly lower the carried interest on
spices that me that is a fantastic story
yeah i hope that came from i hope that's
the yeah i got the etymology
if we look at a lot of the the current
day norms or we could just look at
recent norms those could be
different instruments like convertible
debt in
early stage venture capital deals just
because i'm more familiar with that
world different types of standardized
documents that are used by places like y
combinator and so on
these were all innovations at some point
that really rocked the boat or changed
things even though they're viewed as
quite
normal now what were some of the
not just what were they but how did you
and possibly partners arrive at some of
the innovations
that that drove the success of the
carlyle group
well as john kennedy said uh victory has
a thousand fathers and defeated an
orphan
so i'll tell you some of the things we
think that were we did that were
successful
but a lot of people now take credit for
it um at the time we thought we were
novel
let me give you an example in the
private equity world when the kkr
deal for rjr was done in 1989 i think
kkr had about seven investment
professionals
they were very small firm but the firms
were very small then and one of the
reasons the firms were small
is that you were only allowed in those
days to have one fund
so if you raised the buyout firm and you
were kkr
uh or some equivalent firm uh you had to
spend 100 of your time managing that
fund
which makes sense that people gave you
money i i came up with an idea which i
thought was novel at the time now maybe
people other people said they did the
same thing i don't know but i it seemed
it seemed to me that after we raised our
small buyout fund at carlisleman
um i said to my partners you are the
investment professionals
you know how to invest the money i'm
really not in an mba
when my skill set is i know how to go
out and raise the money
and i'm pretty good at recruiting people
so here's what i have
in mind let's build the fidelity or t
row price
of private equity which is to say not
have one buyout fund but have a buyout
fund
a venture fund a growth fund a real
estate fund and basically take our brand
name
and as fidelity had done and as t rowe
price had done and vanguard
have many different funds and therefore
institutionalize
our brand name institutionalize our
business by centralizing fundraising
accounting tax and everything in one
place
let's say our headquarters in washington
and then we have multiple funds and the
theory is
if you liked us and buyouts give us a
chance in venture capital if you'd like
us some buyouts in venture capital give
us a chance at something else
and that more or less worked and we
built that an institutional business and
the second idea was to globalize it
when kkr did this rjr deal everybody did
deals in their own country
to the extent that deals were done in
asia they were all minority state
transactions but they were buyouts in
europe they were basically done by
europeans americans did american deals
and latin americans did latin deals the
extent they were doing them i said why
don't we go and recruit a european team
an asian team a japanese team middle
east team african team latin american
team and then have our own people that
we
control they work for the firm but we're
doing global so we basically built an
institutional firm
and a global firm and that was the
novelty of it and i became
known as a well-known fundraiser because
as we're raising all these funds i had
to be the person running around the
world
trying to get the money so i you know i
would travel an enormous amount
of time to raise money for these funds
did you start with that end in mind in
some sense you've
you've been described as a virtuous of
private fundraising were you
thinking about in your mind's eye
how to differentiate carlisle
in fundraising and then building the
product
around that in a sense with the
multi-geography
approach multi-product like you said
sort of fidelity type approach
did that come from your strength as a
fundraiser and thinking about
how you would be most effectively able
to pitch this
some extent i mean i don't want to pat
myself on the back but i realized that i
once i raised the fund and i wasn't i
was on the investment committee so they
still am but i'm not
day-to-day doing the deals um so i would
say well i have
time i could go out and raise another
fund i could recruit people for a fund
and then i run a fund and let me go
raise money around them and then my
partners could oversee the investments
so i i did think that that was something
that i could do
and it worked out and and so i built a
large in-house fundraising team
historically
when you were raising a fund firms would
use third-party people to raise the the
funds for them
because nobody really wanted to be a
fundraiser um you know
people who were doing deals that was the
high part of the food chain doing a deal
you're a private equity
investor at the low point of the food
chain was being the fundraiser because
nobody really wanted to go out
and ask for money it's unpleasant people
thought and just not
seemly but i didn't have anything else
that better that i could add to the firm
so i said all right i'll go out and
recruit the people
and then i'll raise the money and i was
willing to do that
one other innovation we came up with for
which we got criticized
but it may be helped us as well and
others have now used it because we're in
washington dc
we had a lot of former government people
who were leaving the government
and they sometimes they didn't really
you know want to go practice law or they
weren't lawyers so
we recruited frank carlucci who's
leaving the reagan administration of
secretary of defense
and four years later we recruited jim
baker former secretary of state
and when these people join our firm and
we brought in other people like arthur
levitt the former head of the sec
dick garman the former head of omb
george herbert walker bush is an advisor
we became very well known because we had
these famous people now they weren't
doing deals but you know if you were
invited to a dinner
with david rubenstein in those days you
wouldn't show up if you're right into a
dinner with jim baker you probably show
up
so that was it was really a a not an
original idea of inviting people
uh to a dinner or an event where there's
a draw that's
obviously something that a lot of people
have used for many times we
we did that and then eventually it kind
of backfired on us a bit because
we had so many ex-government people
people thought we were uh
lobbying the government or doing
inappropriate things we weren't doing
that
but it backfired a bit when because when
george w bush became president
and his uh and the war in iraq went went
south
uh we were for whatever reason blamed
for it and so people thought well you
know the father is
connected to the firm and jim baker's in
the firm he's close to bush
so we we basically had to change our
image a bit and i i recruited lou
gerstner then
hiring at the age of 60 which seems very
young today
to retire he retired from ibm at 60 and
i
recruited him to be the chairman of
carlisle and then the government people
kind of retired when
that all went down with respect to the
iraq war and so on the
the accusations associated with that how
did that affect you
if it did you just you seem at least
from a lot of the reading to be
very unflappable did it have a
significant
impact on you or did you take it
stoically and
you know keep calm carry on how did that
experience
uh sort of travel through you if that
makes any sense well it wasn't
it was not a highlight of my life
because you know one day you're doing
private equity deals
and you think you're doing a reasonably
good job at it for your investors and
all of a sudden
people are attacking you as being the
people behind the iraq war which we have
nothing to do with
so um it wasn't a pleasant experience
and our image i think was hurt
so we looked at what we had to do and
what we had to do was kind of decouple
ourselves from the people
who were not responsible for it either
but just having an association with
political people
probably engendered more criticism than
probably worth
and so all those people volunteered to
kind of retire from the firm and then we
brought in
lou gerstner as i mentioned and we try
to de-politicize our image
and so um you know i would say it's was
a painful experience but
you know lots of things in life are
painful you live through them you do the
best you can
if we come back to your reputation as a
a virtuoso of fundraising
what mistakes do you think novice
fundraisers
make what are some of the more common
mistakes that you've seen
in your career well in the fundraising
world there are three types of
fundraising
basically there's political fundraising
there's philanthropic and there's
business
in many ways business is the easier of
them
because you're offering people rate of
return and and therefore
they're theoretically gonna get their
money back and plus get more money
uh philanthropic is more challenging
because you're asking people to do
something for the good of the
country or the good of the organization
and it's more
ephemeral as to what the benefit is and
political the amounts are relatively
smaller so
probably not as challenging but in the
mistakes that i see people
make are number one they say i'm sorry
to ask you for money
well if you're sorry don't do it if you
want you want people to give you money
you should tell them why they should
give it to you you should know what
you're talking about
you should have as much information at
your fingertips
you shouldn't have to keep saying i'll
get back to you i'll get back to you
should know the information
yourself or have somebody with you who
can do it you should always be
uh polite and appropriately so uh not
arrogant
you should give people a chance to think
about it
you should give people a follow-up note
or card after the meeting is over
and then appropriate time follow up and
see what what's done
and then keep them informed all the time
about how
the investment they might have made is
doing you shouldn't raise money from
people
and then not talk to them again until
you're ready to raise another fund
obviously even if you treat people not
as well as you should if the returns are
spectacular people will probably
reinvest with you
but returns are probably going to be in
the median and therefore
not so spectacular that people will give
you money no matter what you do so
treating people appropriately is good
but knowing what you're doing in the old
days it used to be
important to show up it was the kind of
thing where if you really
cared for me and you want my money show
up and show you care
now in the era of zoom you can't show up
and so it turns out it's a lot easier to
raise money today if you have an
established fund
because you have a track record people
already know you it's a lot harder to
raise money if you're doing it for a
first time because people really can't
meet with you
and they can't meet with you they
probably have a better excuse not to
invest with you
but in the end it's not anything more
challenging than doing the kind of
things you would want people to do which
is give you information be transparent
be honest get bad news up front
interestingly
if you go to harvard business school
stanford business school or any other
good business school wharton
universicago are all very good places
and you say you know what i want to be a
fundraiser i don't want to be a manager
i don't want to be an investor i don't
want to be anything i want to be a
fundraiser
i don't think you'll probably find a lot
of fundraising courses or maybe none
because people don't view it as a skill
set that's worth intellectual
time but i do think that people who
actually know something about
fundraising
i'm not looking for a job but people
noticing about fundraising
should probably you know uh teach what
it takes to
ask for money for example you've been in
the business world and
you would know that your experience is
like mine if i go to
an audience any any audience and i say
how many people in the last month
have been asked for money for a
philanthropic political or
um business thing and half the people
will probably raise their hand
and say how many people have asked other
people not been asked but asked the
other half will raise their hands in
other words
everybody is asking people for money or
being asked it's a very common thing in
society
but it isn't treated as an intellectual
kind of a difficult thing and therefore
you don't tend to get courses in it
there are very few books written about
you know private equity fundraising or
things like that but anyway
so in the embryonic stages of
the carlyle group two questions the
first is
did you have a placeholder name before
it was called
the carlyle group and second what did
that
initial fundraise look like how much
were you trying to raise you now have
approximately 230 billion under
management what were you trying to raise
then
if you look at the original business
plan for apple
microsoft amazon or any great company i
wouldn't say we're in that league
you will see that the original business
plan probably bore a little relation to
the company that they actually
turned out to be because the world
changes and so forth remember jeff bezos
was only going to sell books
that was his plan he didn't really think
about doing anything else till much
later
or at least a few years later in our
case we originally decided to have
a name that would be one of the usual
greek and roman names that you can
roll you know that you're naming it for
roman or greek goddesses but
all the ones we looked at were either
taken or we couldn't pronounce them
so then we came up with a thing that
says uh how about why don't we just say
what we are
washington international finance and
investment corporation
but people pointed out that didn't
exactly roll off one's tongue
was too long and so one of my partners
said well what about carlisle
because he had read a book about the man
named andre myer
who was the then running lazard freyr
and he lived at the carlisle hotel in
new york
and had us he was not married he had a
nice lifestyle
and i guess my friend our partner at the
time aspired to live
in the carlisle hotel and and have a
kind of a single man's lifestyle in the
carlisle hotel
and it you know it seemed like a good
easily pronounceable
name it sounded a little british and
therefore maybe it sounded like we had
some you know class behind us and so
we went with it and
what was the initial target fundraise
how much money were you
aiming to raise well we originally
wanted to raise
5 million not 5 billion but 5 million
and so a friend of mine who is now in
the firm helped us get it done
we raised it from four investors one a
west coast bank
uh one was t rowe price one was alex
brown
and the other was the melon family out
of pennsylvania
and ultimately they put up the five
million dollars and then after about a
year or so
the mellon family bought the others out
and so they were became our main partner
let's double click on that because
you've mentioned it was hard to get a
job you were calling these people who
had expressed
all of this hot interest in you when you
were
a player at the white house and then no
return calls
what were some of the key decisions or
factors that allowed you to raise
that money well the five million was
really raised because
um the person who was helping us was a
man from t
rowe price um and he was a friend of
mine he helped us
his name is ed matthias he ultimately
became part of our firm later on
but he basically had a really good
network and again five million dollars
isn't that much it was
two million to operate the firm and
three million dollars to invest
we were going to each time we had a deal
we would raise money on a deal by deal
basis
that was the theory it was a little
challenging to do that from time to time
but so it wasn't that much money
obviously in our first fund
we ultimately went out to raise a fund
at one point after a couple years and we
raised 100 million dollars
and so that was all we could raise our
second fund was about a billion
or so but that was because we had
invested a lot of money alongside the
100 million dollar fund co-invested it
and our track worker was good
if you have a good track record you can
raise an infinite amount of money
if you're you know do reasonable things
to ask people for money
if you have a bad track record you know
no matter how polite you ask it may not
make much difference
when you say good track record could you
give people an idea
of what that track record looked like
yes
we in our first couple deals we we were
making maybe two
three four times our money on some of
the early deals and that was pretty good
they were small deals and they weren't
you know gigantic deals but they were
good enough to give people
a sense that yeah we probably knew what
we were doing and we were okay and i
think people
were willing to take a chance on us but
it's a concentric circle first you
raise money from your friends and your
relatives
then you raise money from people you
might know in your city then you state
then you're you know region then you
know the country than other countries
and so you just kind of work your way
around the world eventually uh
i learned that no matter where you go in
the world there are always people that
basically have been educated in
investments
and in business and they talked the same
language ebitda
cash flow multiples p e ratios you know
carried interest they all had a
sense of what you're talking about in
the end generally you find when you peel
the onion you find that somebody in any
organization
it really the person that knows
something about what you're talking
about and they won't be the one that
probably makes
the decision what did you do differently
from other fundraisers if you had to
pick one or two things
you know looking back what did you do
differently i mean you were clearly
a top performer within that skill set
uh what did you do differently would you
say well uh
for one it was novel to have a big
in-house fundraising team at that time
now it's fairly common for large firms
but in the old days i was saying earlier
if you were raising a fund you're
probably only raising one fund a year or
every couple years
so you would go out and hire merrill
lynch or lizard freyr or somebody that
had a full-time team that did nothing
but raise money
i built an in-house team that was
unusual and it was all around the world
and i heavily incented them they were
heavily
uh rewarded for doing well so we were
paying our fundraisers
probably more than the market would
dictate we had to and as a result we
got very good people and we retained
very good people and then i was willing
to
uh slept around the world go anywhere
see anybody do anything to kind of help
make the case and so
since i was a founder of the firm and i
was willing to run around the world
you know i could see a lot of people and
people kind of respected the fact that i
would show up in
you know places that many people didn't
show up in very often
if you're open to saying a little bit
more about compensation i'd be very
curious to know
how you ultimately at least at that
point in time ended up
incentivizing your fundraisers
well fundraisers tend to get compensated
in any business world or any salesman as
generally you can call them fundraisers
here
salesmen generally get compensated as a
percentage of the revenue they bring in
or some percentage of something and so
we we had a kind of
percentage that we would pay people and
if they had a spectacular
year we wouldn't say well you're making
too much money this year so we'll we'll
cut the percentage or we won't give you
as much as you're entitled to
so we would honor our commitments now
therefore we our fundraisers were very
highly compensated
in hindsight we could have changed the
way we structured it now we've got a
system that's a little bit more
complicated in terms of we say well you
get compensated more
if it's a harder fun to raise compensate
less if it's an easier fun to raise so
forth and so on
but i at the time to get it going i was
not
interested in that nuance i just wanted
to get into the market get the money
raised
and so we probably were more generous
than than maybe other people
you mentioned a name earlier that i know
is featured in your book how to lead
wisdom from the world's greatest ceos
founders and game changers and that is
jeff bezos
right now the implicit in the in the
title how to lead is
is that one can learn at least how to be
a better
leader and you have a tremendous list of
names of those you've interviewed jeff
bezos ruth bader ginsburg
phil knight oprah and so on what are
some of the deepest impressions
that have been made on you from your
time with jeff bezos
what are what are the sort of learnable
or emulatable
aspects of jeff well jeff is a very
smart person
very hard working my interview he
pointed
out some of his tricks which i wish i'd
known which is getting eight hours of
sleep every night i've
you know i could have gotten more sleep
over the last you know 30 years i
realized that was the key
doesn't make decisions before 10 in the
morning doesn't really make decisions
late in the afternoon tries to make only
a limited number of big decisions
in a week or so so he's very creative
and very smart
um i first met him after our company
helped him get in the business because
when he was selling books over the
internet that was his plan he had to get
a bibliography of books in print
and one of our companies had such a
bibliography and we rented it to him
later i realized that probably we should
have taken his original deal which was
the
i think it was 20 or 30 percent of the
stock of his new company amazon
uh in return for renting the
bibliography but we said no we wanted
cash
so that was probably a mistake but i
went out to see him
first time and said i'd rather have that
20 or 30 percent
he said well david that was two years
ago i don't need you so much anymore but
you were very helpful when he did give
us some stock
and that stock was probably maybe one
percent of the company which today is
worth what
you know 20 billion dollars or something
like that so
uh i probably should have held on to the
stock but we sold it pretty quickly
any other tricks or
mental frameworks anything that really
stand out for you
from jeff in term from jeff well jeff
is a person that has uh like a lot of
very successful business people a lot of
self-confidence
he's got a pretty good sense of humor if
you read the interview you can see that
he can laugh at himself
and he uh has pretty good insights as to
what works and doesn't work he
as he said intuition is what he really
relies on his gut
um if he relied on consultants he
probably never would have started the
company
so i would say uh jeff is uh is an
easy guy to get along with in many
respects and if you think about it
he's now the richest man in the world
and let's say up until maybe a couple
days ago the second richest was bill
gates
if you think about it when you're the
richest person in the world it can tend
to be
isolating many people been the richest
people in the world have tended to
isolate themselves jay paul getty was
relatively reclusive howard hughes was
extremely reclusive
daniel ludwig who maybe was the first
billionaire in the united states was
relatively reclusive
uh now you have these multi-billionaires
he's sent to billionaires
and they are accessible i mean you know
they're not walking around the street
like everybody else but they
you know they go to meetings and they
you know you can get meetings with them
you can do interviews of them then
you know it's much different phenomenon
than you saw years ago
i think jeff is a person that's has
built an incredible company when you
think about it the company didn't start
i think to 1994
and now the company's got a million
employees and
market cap of about 2 trillion dollars
it's just staggering what he's built in
a relatively short period of time yeah
the annual letters also are just
fantastic
there are for people listening pdfs of
the collected annual letters
to shareholders and they make for a
really really good read
just a little easter egg for people if
they haven't run into it
if you go to relentless.com that will
redirect to amazon.com that was
an initial pet url from jeff bezos
ruth bader ginsburg what struck you or
stayed with you
most from your time with her her passing
had a tremendous
while her life certainly had a
tremendous impact on on countless
countless millions and her death had a
huge impact on a lot of people close to
me
also what were things that stood out
about her to you
well she was very diminutive i've
interviewed her a few times one time was
in the book
for the book i did that at the 92nd
street y in new york
very small if she weighed 100 pounds i'd
be surprised
90 pounds of that was probably her brain
brilliant person
first in her class at harvard law school
first in her class at columbia law
school a time when
women were barely admitted to law
schools and she couldn't get a job
but it is complicated person to
interview in some respects because
when you interview her you she would not
respond right away in other words if you
ask me a question within
you know a minute any second i'm going
to give you an answer maybe i shouldn't
but i do
and that's what most people do she would
sit there for like 20
seconds am i is she having a senior
moment
is there a health problem she can't hear
that well did i say something wrong
but no apparently she did that her whole
life she actually had this incredible
habit of
thinking before she talked imagine that
thinking before you talk
and so she would think very carefully
what she want to say and then she would
say it
so a lot of times people were put off by
that but i wasn't
i got to know her reasonably well
because as a chair of the kennedy center
she would come
relatively frequently to see operas and
uh and she you know get the gigantic
standing ovation so i realize after a
while
i have to be careful because every time
i would announce she was there it would
be a 20-minute standing ovation
and you know president of the united
states would get a two-minute standing
ovation she would get 20 minutes
so we had to kind of calibrate the times
we'd introduce her because we knew it
would set things back by 20 minutes but
she deserved it because she
had really represented women in a time
when women weren't really being
represented
for gender equality and she
revolutionized and really created the
gender
equality law that we now have and
and then as a member of the supreme
court for more than 20 years she really
helped
write some historic opinions you've
interviewed and certainly have met
many iconic figures the names that we've
mentioned
known to millions does anyone pop to
mind
anyone you've spent time with who is an
extraordinary leader
who is perhaps lesser known they could
be well known within a niche
or within a uh a particular industry but
just is in terms of
broad mainstream awareness perhaps are
not as well known as some of
the names that we've mentioned well
there there are always people
that uh you interview who are not as
well known as i think they should be
they've done great things but they're in
a
narrow niche or something but let me
before i respond to that in detail i
would say that
as somebody that does interviewing
yourself you've done i don't know how
many podcasts is it 500 or a thousand or
something about 500.
right 500. it's an interesting format
when you think about it
why don't we have any interview
transcripts of
julius caesar william shakespeare
charlemagne alexander the great
henry viii abraham lincoln well this
format of
interviewing people for information and
to some extent entertainment
is a relatively new phenomenon in the
grand scheme of intellectual development
and civilization you know obviously
lawyers uh depose
people and that's happens in court but
as a way to kind of learn
reading an interview and listening to an
interview and being an interview is a
relatively new phenomenon i kind of
attributed going back to maybe
the early days of the tonight show in
the 1950s when people went on television
they were interviewed
and people thought it was not only
interesting but entertaining
and as you know presumably podcasts and
other things are now
and i just wish i had a chance to go
back and interview some of these people
you think about if we had an interview
of george washington interview of
abraham lincoln
interview of henry viii you know you
could say to henry eighth why why didn't
you just get a prenup and not
and not uh you know chop off the heads
of all these uh
wives you had or or alexander the great
couldn't have attached a little more
modest name to your
to yourself rather than the great i mean
just it's been fun to interview people
like that
in terms of your specific question i
interview a lot of historians for
programs that i have
uh history programs and they have
incredible stories to tell
they themselves are not as famous as the
people they're writing about
many ways but they know the person so
well that they can you feel like you're
talking the person so
when you talk to robert carro who's
spent 35 years of his life
working on lyndon johnson you feel like
you're you're talking to lyndon johnson
or when you talk to doris kearns goodwin
you feel like you can you really
understand lincoln or the other people
she's written about fdr or so many other
people
so i often like to interview writers as
well because they can do a terrific job
of
explaining things in ways that you
didn't really understand before
you mentioned robert carrow and lbj
also the author as i know you know of
the power broker
and right when you established
the the carlyle group you you
established it in washington dc instead
of on wall street
and i would love to and this is just my
personal curiosity talk
about your perception of power
in politics because i'm familiar with
money as a currency in the world of
business and investing
i'm familiar with say status within the
world of
research and academia the different
flavors or species
of political power though are not a
native language of mine i really haven't
had much exposures when you spend time
in a nexus of political power like
washington dc
what are the the different forms
that it takes because there are
certainly many
benevolent drives among those who are
forming policy and then there
there seems to be also i mean a drive to
power and i'd just love to hear given
the amount of
time you've spent what your experience
of and perception is of
of power well throughout history some
people
have like to have power because it gives
them a sense of control
over their lives and the lives of others
makes them feel more important it makes
them feel maybe they can accomplish
something if just the
thrill of having power isn't enough for
them they want to actually accomplish
something with a power
and it's uh intoxicating in many ways as
henry kissinger famously said
power is the ultimate aphrodisiac in
washington dc
you could be a wealthy billionaire or
multi-billionaire
and try to meet with a senator or
congressman or a cabinet officer
and they may not care how wealthy you
are because if you don't have power
in washington you're a dead person so
you know people in washington care more
about who the chairman of the ways and
means committee is
then who is the uh you know the the ceo
of a major company
people uh in washington they care about
who's got a an important job in the
white house
more than they care about who's starting
an s venture capital fund that's going
to be a
a terrific venture capital fund so
washington is a place where
power really is the ultimate card and
that means something to people
and it's interesting when you don't have
the power you know you're out hailing a
cab with everybody else
but when you have the power you can get
almost anything done and you want in
washington that's what people in
washington
have as their currency the corner of the
realm here is having power
and money isn't as important in
washington as it is in virtually every
other city
you've studied history you've studied
the
historians who write history and
i've spent a lot of time certainly
restoring preserving
highlighting re-highlighting history in
many many different ways through your
philanthropy
if you look back as someone who i
believe you know
as you mentioned aims to read 100 or so
books per year
if you had to pick you know one or two
books that really highlight
power of the white hat variety meaning
the
the use and wielding of power for the
forces of light
sounds very grandiose but i think you
get the idea and then you know one or
two
that exemplify the opposite you know
someone who is perhaps
overly intoxicated that fell into a
delirium or just was otherwise wielding
it in more of a black hat manner
do any books biographies or otherwise
come to mind for either of those
well um i there's a new book out that
i've interviewed the authors on
uh peter baker and uh susan glasser
about jim baker
who was the ultimate gold standard as
white house chief of staff under ronald
reagan and then the secretary of
treasury and secretary of state
it's basically i wouldn't say it's
completely favorable but it's pretty
favorable
about what he did it has some of his
warts in there as we all have words he
was a
partner in our firm for a number of
years so i know him quite well it's a
really good read on
power in washington dc because for 12
years he had
an incredible amount of power i think
the
book that won the pulitzer prize for
robert carro
uh was the book on lyndon johnson in the
senate
and that is the best book about what
it's like to have
legislative power and a terrific read
i'd say presidential books the ones that
i
like are i think ted sorensen's book on
uh
on kennedy was a great look inside the
kennedy white house from an insider
the terrific book arthur celestine who
wrote a really good book as well about
the kennedy administration though those
books were written before we have a lot
of information that we now have
they didn't really have then i'd say
most presidents have
biographies that are pretty flattering
there's another one out now that's not
completely flattering on my former boss
jimmy carter by jonathan alter
a very good book really the first
full-length biography of jimmy carter
that has the good and the bad in there
people tend not to write books about
presidents
that say how terrible they are um
i mean obviously books about andrew
johnson are not going to be that
favorable or
james buchanan are not that favorable
probably warren harding are not that
favorable
but generally the people who write books
if they're writing them they're
generally you have to live with somebody
for three four five years to do that
you're generally
going to do it if you find reasonably
good things about a person to say
you generally don't want to spend three
or four or five years of your life
writing a book about somebody you
actually hate
so you don't usually get terrible books
about people
they do point out their warts
autobiographies written by presidents
tend to be in a fairly unique category
because they're not going to say how
terrible they are they don't usually put
out all of their insecurities or so
forth
but some people have written really good
books uh who are presidents and
it you know it's it's a genre that uh i
think is not one where
you get a lot of pulitzer prizes from
people who've written presidential
autobiographies but
uh the new one by uh barack obama i
haven't read yet but i
hear it's pretty very well written
because he's a very good writer
but it's only one of the two volumes so
it's not complete yet
do you read any fiction or is it
entirely nonfiction
that's a good question i do not read
fiction we all have our failings in life
we all have our weaknesses
but um my theory is that i'd like to get
as much information as i can
and so more factual information is
probably in
non-fiction than fiction books so i
recognize a lot of research is done for
good fiction books
you know i tend to read books that i
know something about so i to read a
hundred books a year
and a meaningful books you've got to
have a system and to do it
uh one of the ways i get to get it done
is i'm interviewing authors all the time
and so i have to read the book so i kind
of force myself to do it
but i also i'm reading books about
things i know pretty well so history
business um philanthropy or
politics things i know reasonably well
so you know i've read you know when i
read the
23rd book on john kennedy you know that
point i i know it br
pretty well so it's not that hard for me
to get through it if i had to read a
physics textbook or a chemistry textbook
it would take me about 10 years to
probably get through it so to read a lot
of books i'm reading things on things i
know reasonably well and can absorb it
pretty quickly
and and i can get through them pretty
pretty readily
how do you choose those books i mean
even though you're reading
a hundred books let's just call it per
year
i know that you feel like you're in as
we all are a race against time
you know you're not right you know we're
all in the process of
sort of trending towards extinction
personal
distinction how do you choose your books
right because some people listening
might hear a 23rd book and that might be
an exaggeration but
i know you've read a lot of books that
overlap how do you choose the books that
you dedicate time to
and and do you ever quit books do you
ever stop when you're part way through
um i generally when i realize i'm
reading a book that isn't that well
written
or not as good as i thought i might just
skip to the chapters that i think i
really care about
so sometimes i generally don't like to
do that but i generally
feel that sometimes books are not as
great i won't mention some
that i've read recently where i said why
did i pick this book i'm going to
interview this author
in this book i can't even get through
this book it's just not you know i mean
english is
you know not the person's native
language i i suspect i can't believe
this book
but you know i never would tell anybody
that i do think it's a courtesy to read
the book if you're interviewing the
author so i try to do that that's the
way i force-feed
myself a bit and i don't have any
disrespect for fiction i just
tend not to be as a big a fiction reader
as i probably should have been or i was
when i was younger
but in terms of the way i picked the
books is i
i love to go to bookstores and caress
the books
pick them up look at them you know
figure out what's what
might be appealing secondly um i read
the book reviews of you know new york
times and other places to see what's
coming out there
and then i'm now in the in the category
of people sometimes send me books
friends of mine are writing books all
the time and so i get a lot of those
books
and then people think i might be a good
for a blurb so people send me books that
they want me to put a blurb on or
say something about it and uh and
generally in in subjects i know
something about people tend to send me
books on
i i you know just do it that way but
what i wanted to comment about the books
though is this
this is very important to me um i care
about books because it opened a new
world for me and that's why i love
reading because i can learn so much and
you know i get wherever i got in life i
got through education
and by education i mean learning
continuously when i give a commencement
speech
i like to tell students look the word
commencement begins
means beginning not the end so don't
think you're educated you're just
beginning
and i i remind people that uh 30 of
americans who graduate from college
never read another book in their life
50 of americans have not bought a new
book in a bookstore
or ordered a book online in the last
five years 50
and so that's called other literacy you
can read but you choose not to
and i think reading books is better than
reading newspaper articles or
or magazine articles which i read an
enormous amount as well but books focus
the mind it takes
you know many hours to get to a book and
therefore it has a certain concentration
skill
which is useful the other problem which
is even more serious is illiteracy
it turns out that 14 of americans are
functionally illiterate they can't read
past the fourth grade level
and i don't mean that they came from
from a spanish-speaking country and they
they can read spanish not english
i don't mean that i mean they can't read
it in spanish either and it's a sad
situation uh 80
of the people in the juvenile
delinquency system are functioning
illiterate and two-thirds of the people
in our federal prison system are
functioning illiterate
that is one of the greatest causes of
income inequality if people can't read
if you can't read you're not going to
get very far in life
in my view so i i really try to urge
people and i've set up a lot of
literacy kind of things to kind of
encourage people to do more but
obviously
i'm a drop in the bucket compared to
what is necessary
what do you consider some of the most
leveraged
or intelligent ways to address that
problem because
you're very effective i think in
in a lot of your giving very thoughtful
and a lot of people are not there's feel
good philanthropy then there's do good
philanthropy and there's a lot
in between in terms of addressing
illiteracy what are some of the
most surgical sort of highly leveraged
approaches in your mind
well to answer that question i'd say as
a general rule i try to find things that
i can start
in philanthropy i can finish in
philanthropy i'm likely to be alive to
see the benefit of it and i have some
intellectual interest in it
literacy is something i've created the
literacy awards the library of congress
and try to do some things there
but i don't have enough money or enough
time on the on the face of this earth
to uh really tackle something as big as
literacy it's a gigantic problem
i think we just need to do a better job
of keeping people from dropping out of
high school for one thing we have
1.7 million people dropping out of high
school each year many of those cases
it's for the
lack of literacy they just lost interest
or other issues but
people dropping out of a high illiteracy
factor so
i i don't have a solution for it if i
did i would have been would have been in
iowa new hampshire
maybe running for president but uh but i
decided not to run for president because
i'm too young
i'm only 71 years old and nobody so
young and inexperienced could probably
get to be president so
i i didn't go to iowa new hampshire but
to be very serious i i think it's one of
the kind of problems we should get more
people to focus on
you rarely rarely i can't even think of
when the last time a president united
states
talked about the importance of literacy
and importance of reading
and i i think if we can get people to
read and not drop out of high school
that would be a big push towards ending
uh not ending but reducing
income inequality and enhancing social
mobility
yeah i agree uh it's it could mitigate
that
i think tremendously there's there's a
if you have the time there's an
outstanding organization very innovative
uh called quest bridge based in the bay
area that
that does uh some excellent work with
addressing
some of the missing pieces in terms of
matching
and sourcing talent to scholarships
and that helps to kind of span that that
that missing piece between high school
and college
i'd like to ask you about kids i have
kids on my mind i don't yet have any
but i'm planning on parenthood in the
not too distant future
and i've heard you speak to
the benefits the advantages
of growing up working class
and i'd love to hear you
describe your advice
to new parents who may have
scrapped their way to some modicum of
success or
financial security as to
how not to
raise kids who are complacent or
entitled or any of those things it's
i've seen very few i have seen examples
of it done
well but i haven't seen that many and
i'm just curious to hear
your thoughts and what advice you would
give jackie kennedy famously said
raising you know if you mess up raising
your children nothing else in life
matters
and she's right and it's the hardest
thing in the world to do people have
been doing it
forever and some people have done a bad
job of it some people have done a good
job
it's not easy to do if anybody knew how
to perfectly raise children they would
have told people by now and everybody
followed it so it's not easy i would say
it's easier
to be a child in many respects when
you're not from a wealthy family because
you don't
you realize you're gonna have to make it
on your own so poverty is not a
wonderful thing i'm not saying people
should be raised in poverty and it's
gonna be good for them
but if you come from a lower middle
class family as maybe i did or a blue
collar family
in hindsight it's it's a great thing i
wish the times that my parents had more
money i could have gotten certain things
i wanted that i didn't get
but in the end i realized if i wasn't
getting anywhere i had to make it on my
own
my own children have grown up in a time
i have three children growing up in a
time when
you know i would have been reasonably
wealthy by any normal human standards
not by bill gates or jeff bezos
standards but by any normal human
centered
a very wealthy person so how do you
raise them in that context well one
don't give them too much money don't buy
them all the things they want
make them do well in school by by
showing them
how important it is to you that they do
well in school don't
flash your money in front of them or
other people
i try to live a more modest lifestyle
now if you're very wealthy
you don't have to be a take a valid
poverty all of a sudden
but i do think it's not good to kind of
uh make your children think that they're
going to have money
their whole life if they don't work so i
have made an enormous number of speeches
saying i'm giving away all my money i
hope my children are
are listening to these speeches i try to
give them a good education they've all
gone to really good schools
they all have mbas which you could say
is either good or bad maybe they're not
struggling artists they're not poets or
not
painters or something maybe that's good
or bad but all of them seem to be
pretty interested in uh in investing and
and capitalism and
and and but doing socially good things
so they have money that i have given
them to give away
um not staggering sums but enough that
they can taste
the pleasure of philanthropy and which
is important to me but i want them to be
able to do it in a way where
they really understand the value of it
it's their decision and they have to
make the decision about
how to follow through and so forth but
look raising children is not easy
you'll find out if you get children that
it's one of the great pleasures of life
that's why so many people want to have
children
but it's also one of the great struggles
of life how do you raise children and
people you know always say to me well
when do you stop worrying about your
children i say probably
when they're about 70 or 75 you may not
worry about them that much because
you're always worrying about your
children
and because you know something can
always go wrong and it's a fear every
parent has which is that their child
will not be happy or healthy
you know at this point in your life what
do you
fear if anything i mean do you have any
present fears or recurrent fears
well i guess um i'm 71 so i would like
to be able to live
a reasonable life and my parents made it
to 85 and 86 it means my genes are
reasonably good if i don't do something
stupid or have a bad accident so i think
my fears are
not getting everything done before i my
time is up
so i call what i'm doing now sprinting
to the finish line
i'm now trying to get things done i
probably should have done a long time
ago but i didn't do i'm
at 70 i came out with my first book at
71 my second book
i'm trying to do one book a year what
was i doing in my 30s 40s 50s and 60s
why wasn't i writing books then
i wish i was you know i have a bucket
list of things i place i haven't been
things i want to go do i haven't done
yet because i've been working pretty
hard my life and
haven't really relaxed in quite the
traditional sense
but you know maybe i'll get to do some
of that but i i want to
you know just get more things done i
want to give away the money that i have
committed to giving away i want to kind
of do the kind of patriotic
philanthropy things i'm interested in
doing i'm involved in a lot of
universities and medical research i want
to see those projects
finished the center that i can so you
know and and then
you know i want to do it in a way that
would make my children proud of me and
uh
you know my parents were proud and i
often ask people
uh in my interviews if you've seen them
i generally get around to saying well
did your parents live long enough to see
your success and people ask me why do
you ask that all the time and i said
well one of the great pleasures in life
is seeing a child grow to be successful
and i want to know whether a child
really had that before their parents
passed away if they did
and i try to try to remind people that
it's a very good idea if you're
successful even if you're not successful
but if you have the means to do
something
to honor your parents while they are
alive it's a lot more fun
to do that for them and you when they're
alive then when they're not alive and i
made some mistakes in that area i
probably should have done much more to
honor my parents
than i did but when my father passed
away relatively
unexpectedly i realized i really hadn't
done enough to honor him other than you
know he was happy with my
success in life but i i decided to find
something to do and he was a marine he
worked
he was in world war ii so i kind of
realized that the iwo jima memorial was
kind of falling apart
a bit not falling apart but it needed
some repair and so i put up the money to
do it in his honor
but then i realized my mother she could
die suddenly so i
decided to have something named for her
in washington dc and i
uh surprised her brought it to to see
her her name was there
and then i got her to sit down to at the
dinner with ruth bader ginsburg
and which is one of her role models and
she really loved spending a couple hours
with ruth bader ginsburg so
uh but i should have done should have
done that earlier and probably i made a
mistake in not doing that earlier so i
encourage people to try to do do more of
that
are your parents alive they are alive
they are alive and
they must be proud of you right they are
they they
say that they are and they tried and
worked very hard a very similar on some
level similar background
kind of middle class lower middle class
and
you know i'm i'm scrolling through my
mind's eye
thinking of how what honoring them might
look like i'd love to hear you
speak further to that because if someone
listening say it doesn't have the means
to
dedicate a memorial or the connections
invite their parents to a dinner that
might be as meaningful which are amazing
don't get me wrong those are incredible
gifts what advice
or words might you have well i'll give
you some advice
um not that you need my advice but uh
there used to be there was a very used
to be a famous football
coach named bear bryant he used to coach
for alabama
and one time he was hired by a t
to do an advertisement for i think it's
mother's day
and mother's day was traditionally and
has traditionally been the most
used phone day this is when people four
people had cell phones i suspect
and so he went on tv and his mother had
passed away
not too long earlier and they had him do
an ad and said
you know today is mother's day
tomorrow's mother's day
please call your mother i wish i could
but i can't anymore
and it kind of reminded people you know
to call your mother while she's alive
and so when my father passed away my
mother was living alone in florida
and now she didn't want to move back to
where i was living and she didn't want
to
move into any kind of assisted living or
anything so she's living alone in her
house
and i i resolved to call her every
single night
which i did yeah for the remaining five
years of her life
and uh she later told people that you
know that was a highlight of her day was
getting a call every day with
clockwork wherever i was in the world
and so i wouldn't say everybody has to
call their parents every single day
but calling them more frequently is
probably a good idea just to kind of
show some respect and so that doesn't
take a lot of money just to do that
yeah yeah it's got got me thinking uh
yeah filial piety doesn't maybe come as
instinctively in the west at least in
the united states as it does in some
other places when you talk about
sprinting to the finish
line and doing these various things on
your bucket list
i mean you're a hard charging worker and
you're very uh
very diligent in how you've applied
yourself aside from doing
more in a sort of broadly sweeping way
are there any must-do
bucket items for you that are just
non-negotiable i need to do these before
i turn to dust well i just want to make
sure my children are as
prepared for my not being around as
possible so
i'm happy to try to still work on that
there are some philanthropic projects
that i have in mind
that i want to get done before
my time is up you know some in the
patriotic philanthropy area some of the
education areas some of the medical
research area
i like to get those done and i also want
to
do as much as i can to give back to the
country in many ways that's what
patriotic philanthropy
is about to me and i i expect to have a
book out in that
not you know maybe year after next where
a book on
what giving back to one's country it
means uh my next book is going to be
about that's coming out next year is
about
what it means to be an american and um
you know what are the qualities that
make one
an american as opposed to a european or
somebody other country
and so i enjoy writing these books and i
enjoy you know giving speeches and
talking about my thoughts and so i'm
really happy my problem is i'm
now 71 you're not going to live forever
so i'm trying to just get things done
and uh giving away my money an
intelligent way
my children are ultimate legacy that's
an important thing to me
and giving back to the country in
whatever way that i can those are the
things i kind of focus on a bit
just a few more questions and i
appreciate all the time 60 minutes
because of this patriotic philanthropy
as you put it it's called you clark kent
in a suit and tie you've done a lot
of these many things that you have done
that you would put in the category of
patriotic philanthropy
what are you proudest of or
what holds a particularly strong
sort of foothold in your heart is there
anything that really stands out for you
well i would say i'll answer your
question a moment but interestingly when
my mother did pass away i went through
all of her papers
and uh she had scrapbooks of all of my
patriotic philanthropy things and none
of the scrapbooks not none of the
articles about carlisle she was really
interested in what i had done and she
told me
that when i started giving away money to
kind of give back to the country when i
caught patriotic philanthropy
she was extremely proud and that's where
she collected all the articles about
that not so much
carlyle's successes so the interesting
thing about patriotic philanthropy is
it's a relatively small part of my
philanthropy maybe five to ten percent
but it gets 99 of the attention for
whatever reason that's basically because
people aren't doing it so much so
if i you know give a large amount of
money to a cancer center at
a cancer hospital you know that's a good
thing though it's modest compared to
what bill gates or other famous
cancer philanthropists are doing but if
i give 10 million dollars to keep the
washington monument kind of
in reasonable shape that gets an
enormous amount of attention maybe it
should maybe it shouldn't
but i i just i've been surprised at how
many how much attention it gets and how
few other people seem to want to do it
but you know i try to convince a lot of
people at the giving pledge in other
places
that they should do they're a lot richer
than me and many of them
uh to do these same things but doesn't
seem to attract as much tension maybe
because
people think the government should be
doing this i don't know but you know my
mother used to watch it and so
one time i i decided that i wanted the
lincoln memorial which was such a famous
part of our history i thought it needed
some repair
and uh it was kind of run down a bit and
then park service doesn't really have
the money to do everything so i said
i'll put up a certain amount of money to
fix it
and they said let's announce it in front
of lincoln memorial i said okay so we
have an announcement there
and as soon as we're doing it it's
covered on c-span live it starts to snow
so i'm sitting there uh in the snow and
i get a call on my cell phone it's from
my mother she's watching c-span she said
david put your hat on
it's snowing i said okay you know so
your mother's always paying attention
and
you you know um okay so i put my hat on
um
anyway you know i've enjoyed this um you
know fixing the monuments or preserving
documents like the magna carta or
i've historic book collection that is
probably one of the better american
book collections of historic american
books and ultimately i'll give these
things away and to places that seem
appropriate i like putting them on
display and the reason i put them on
display is that
if you look at a computer slide of the
magna carta or if you
read a computer slide of the washer
monument it doesn't have the same impact
as visiting it the human brain
still gets much more out of visiting
something you prepare for it
you learn more when you're there you
learn more afterwards and so i'm trying
to get people to learn more
about our country's history and the
reason is this
if you want to have a good democracy you
have to have an informed citizenry
that's what the founding fathers believe
informed citizenry
will lead to a better democracy right
now we don't teach civics very much in
our country's history
and we don't teach in our country's
schools and we don't teach very much
about american history you can graduate
from almost any
college united states without having to
take an american history course
so uh now the situation is such so bad
that
recently in a survey two-thirds of
americans couldn't even name the three
branches of our federal government
and while 91 percent of people apply for
citizenship tests in this country can
pass the basic
civics test in 49 out of 50 states
recently the majority of citizens
couldn't pass the basic citizenship test
that you have to take to be a citizen
so we just should do a better job of
informing our citizens and that's why
some of the things i do is designed to
kind of get people educated about this
a little bit more than maybe they
otherwise would be if you could get
a message a quote a word an image
anything
out to billions of people metaphorically
speaking on a
huge billboard could be anything what
might you put
on that billboard give back to your
country
do something that makes the world a
better place and your country a better
place
honor your parents your reputation is
all you really carry around with you it
takes a lifetime to build a reputation
and five minutes to destroy it
so don't do anything that destroys your
reputation but do things that will honor
your children your parents and yourself
and give back
to the country which you know you
presumably think is the best country in
the world or you wouldn't be here
really enjoyed this david thank you so
much for the time
appreciate it uh thanks for all your
research you're obviously well
researched and you
know your material pretty well thanks
i do i do my best and people can find
more at davidrubenstein.com the new book
or i should say the latest book but
certainly one of many to come is
how to lead wisdom from the world's
greatest ceos founders and game changers
so anything else that you would like to
to say or request
of my audience before we bring this to a
close no i would just say
i've been interviewed by a lot of
podcast people and you are as
well informed as anybody i've ever been
interviewed by you obviously do a lot of
research
and i appreciate it and you have a very
soothing voice which works quite well on
podcasts
so i know you have done other things in
the business world and so forth but you
have a real
future here and i look forward to
listening to a lot of your podcasts and
to
i'm gonna go back and reread some of
your books okay uh thank you david
i i really appreciate it and uh this is
this has been really enjoyable for me
and perhaps some some point post post
covid will bump into each other
maybe so um but my new book is going to
be seven day work week
we need a seven day workout you know
i was thinking when you were like oh
this this person's native language isn't
even
english i was like you know that could
be a blurb on the back of one of my
books maybe
right let's send a galley for you to
read
but really appreciate it and uh to
everybody listening we'll have notes for
everything at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast hey guys this is
tim again just a few more things before
you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird that i've somehow dug up in
the
the world of the esoteric as i do it
could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you will get
the very next one
and if you sign up i hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
theragun i have
two theraguns and they are worth their
weight in gold i've been using them
every single day whether you're an elite
athlete or just a regular person trying
to get through your day
muscle pain and muscle tension are real
things that's why i use
the theragun i use it at night i use it
after workouts
it is a handheld percussive therapy
device that releases your deepest
muscle tension so for instance at night
i might use it on the bottom of my feet
it's helped with my plantar fasciitis
i will have my girlfriend use it up and
down
the middle of my back and i'll use it on
her it's an easy way for us to actually
trade massages in effect and you can
think of it
in fact as massage reinvented on some
level helps with performance
helps with recovery helps with just
getting your back
to feel better before bed after you've
been sitting for way too many hours
i love this thing and the all-new gen 4
theragun
has a proprietary brushless motor that
is surprisingly quiet
it's easy to use and about as quiet as
an electric toothbrush
it's pretty astonishing you really have
to feel the theragun's
signature power amplitude and
effectiveness to believe it
it's one of my favorite gadgets in my
house at this point so
i encourage you to check it out try
theragun that's thera
t-h-e-r-a-g there's no substitute for
the gen 4 theragon
with an oled screen that's oled for
those wondering that's
organic light emitting diode screen
personalized theragun app an
incredible combination of quiet and
power so go to theragon.com
tim right now and get your gen 4th era
gun today or you can watch the videos
on the site which show you all sorts of
different ways to use it a lot of runner
friends of mine use them on their it
bands after long runs
there are million ways to use it and the
gen fourth era guns start
at just 199 dollars i said i have two
i have the prime and i also have the pro
which is like the super cadillac version
my girlfriend loves these soft
attachments
on that so check it out go to
theragon.com
tim one more time theragun.com
tim this episode is brought to you by
headspace
life could be stressful even under
normal circumstances 2020
has challenged even the most resilient
people
i know it's highlighted just how much we
all need stress relief that goes beyond
quick fixes or really the hope for just
a one and done
band-aid quick is fine but we need stuff
that is durable and that's where
headspace
comes in headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of guided
meditations
in an easy to use app now you might ask
yourself
very reasonably there are 2 000 plus
apps for meditation
why would i use headspace headspace is
one of the only meditation apps advanced
in the field of mindfulness and
meditation through clinically validated
research
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
600 000 5 star reviews and more than 60
million of downloads
so people keep telling you to try
meditation and you're like when would i
do that
when would i possibly have time you
should check out headspace if you have
10 minutes
headspace can change your life headspace
offers
a really light lift and a lot
of features to keep you going which is
part of the reason that i've used
headspace for years now so whatever the
situation headspace can really help you
feel better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation view need
some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions their
members swear by and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
headspace's approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress improve sleep
boost focus and increase your overall
sense
of well-being and it really starts with
very very
simple practices and if you look at
my case for instance i just went through
one of the basics
today with the co-founder andy
it's put a could be pretty calm i'm
not sure but former monk
turned into co-founder of headspace has
the most soothing hypnotic voice
imaginable
and i did a three minute notation
something like that it's easy
it's fundamental and it always puts me
in
a better space so i'm going through the
basics even though i've meditated for
years i'm going through the basics
once again and i would suggest to anyone
that they
consider starting there headspace makes
it easy for you to build a life-changing
meditation practice
with mindfulness that works for you on
your schedule anytime
anywhere we all want to feel happier we
all want more peace
and headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com
tim that's headspace.com tim for a free
one month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
conceivable possible situation you can
break glass in case of emergency in
almost any situation and find something
on headspace this is the best deal
offered right now for headspace
so check it out go to headspace.com
tim today
you